يستعد علي ليوم آخر من العمل
في جناح الطوارئ في مستشفى رفيقة الحريري الجامعي في بيروت ،
المرفق الرئيسي في لبنان الذي يعالج
19 مريضًا ،
وهو عامل في الخطوط الأمامية في
مكافحة الفيروس التاجي ،
وهو ممرض تعافى مؤخرًا فقط من
المرض
وهو يعلم مخاطره.  دعوته
جيدة جدًا ،
هناك خطر يقول علي أنه يمكننا الحصول على
كورونا مثل ما حدث لي ،
لكن في النهاية هذه هي وظيفتنا
التي
اخترناها وعلينا القيام بذلك ، لقد خرج لبنان للتو
من إغلاق على مستوى البلاد لمدة 16 يومًا
لكن وفقًا لمدير المستشفى الدكتور
فراس أبيض ،
فإن الفوائد بعيدة المنال حتى الآن ،
فهذه هي أعلى حصيلة وفيات أسبوعية
أعلى
عدد وفيات أسبوعية منذ
بداية الوباء هنا في لبنان أيضًا ،
وهناك شيء آخر
لاحظناه مؤخرًا وهو عدد الوفيات
التي تحدث.  في المنزل
وبعضها للمرضى الصغار نسبيًا ،
يواجه لبنان عاصفة كاملة
من المشاكل
على رأس الوباء هناك  مع
انفجار ميناء بيروت في
آب / أغسطس الماضي الذي أودى بحياة أكثر من 200 شخص
وألحق أضرارًا
بأجزاء كبيرة من المدينة ،
فإن الاقتصاد في حالة سقوط حر ،
الحكومة مفلسة ويصيبها
شلل سياسي كامل
وتعاني البلاد من اضطرابات متكررة
في الوطن يحاول علي أن  احمي
بناته الصغيرات من الضغوط
والمخاطر في
بعض الأحيان كان علي إخفاء ألمي كما يقول في
بعض الأحيان كان علي أن أخفي مدى
تعبيتي.